[Music]  using selfie for work-based learning  helping vet institutions and training  companies to make the most of digital  technologies  why did you choose to use selfie wbl  i'm a flat  i think that digital skills are  important  because most of my students have  customer relationships today  why was selfie wpl so helpful  it addresses four different target  groups of course learners teachers and  managers but also and it's new it also  addresses companies and in company  trainers  how did selfie wbl improve the quality  of workplace learning  i think i have closer relationship with  the businesses  and it was useful for my students as  well because we could have the same  feedback  benefits  discover your digital potential selfie  for work-based learning  [Music]  you